Pourquoi n'est-ce pas une meilleure solution ?
On économiserait les frais de forage.
EM : Oui, je suis en faveur des engins volants.
Je fais des fusées donc j'aime les choses qui volent.
Je n'ai pas de préjugés contre les objets volants,
mais on rencontre des obstacles avec les voitures volantes :
elles seront assez bruyantes
et la force des vents générés sera très puissante.
Disons que si quelque chose vole au-dessus de votre tête,
comme une multitude de voitures allant dans tous les sens,
ce n'est pas une situation susceptible de réduire le stress.
(Rires)
Vous n'allez jamais penser : « Je me sens mieux aujourd'hui. »
Vous allez vous inquiéter : « Est-ce que leur enjoliveur est à niveau
ou va-t-il se détacher et me guillotiner ? »
Vous voyez le genre.
CA : Donc vous avez cette vision
des villes du futur équipées d'un vaste réseau de tunnels souterrains.
Y a-t-il un lien avec l'Hyperloop ?
Pourriez-vous appliquer cette idée de tunnels à votre concept d'Hyperloop
lancé il y a quelques années ?
EM : Nous avons tâtonné pendant un moment
avec ce projet d'Hyperloop.
Nous avons construit un circuit de test, adjacent à SpaceX,
pour une compétition estudiantine
visant à encourager les idées innovantes en matière de transport.
C'est finalement devenu la plus grande chambre sous vide au monde
après le grand accélérateur de particules du CERN,
en termes de volume.
C'était très amusant à faire, mais c'était surtout un hobby.
On pense alors qu'on pourrait...
On a construit un petit pousseur motorisé pour aider les étudiants
et on va essayer de voir à quelle vitesse ce pousseur peut monter
s'il ne pousse rien.
Nous sommes optimistes mais prudents.
Il sera plus rapide que le plus rapide des TGV
même sur une distance de 13 Km.
CA : Waouh. Mieux vaut avoir de bons freins.
EM : Oui, je veux dire, c'est-- ouais.
Il risque soit d'éclater en miettes, soit d'aller très vite.
CA : Mais vous pouvez donc envisager un Hyperloop dans un tunnel
parcourant de très longues distances.
EM : Tout à fait.
Et au vue des techniques de forage,
il s'avère que pour creuser un tunnel,
il faut,
pour que le tunnel soit hermétique aux nappes phréatiques,
il faut concevoir des murs suffisamment robustes
pour supporter une pression de 5 à 6 fois celle de l’atmosphère.
Pour contenir le vide, il ne faut qu'une atmosphère,
ou un vide quasi total.
En fait, automatiquement,
si un tunnel est capable de résister aux nappes phréatiques,
il est aussi capable de supporter le vide.
CA : Hum.
EM : La réponse est oui.
CA : Pouvez-vous imaginer quelle serait la longueur des tunnels nécessaire
au fonctionnement de l'Hyperloop ?
EM : Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de limite de longueur.
On peut creuser autant que l'on veut.
Et si vous envisagiez la construction de quelque chose
comme un Hyperloop de Washington à New York,
votre cahier des charges mentionnera une ligne entièrement souterraine.
Car c'est une zone à forte densité.
Vous passeriez sous un nombre important d'immeubles et de maisons,
et s'il est suffisamment profond,
le tunnel est indétectable.
Parfois les gens pensent que ce serait assez ennuyant
d'avoir un tunnel sous leur maison.
Si un tunnel est creusé
à une profondeur de 4 à 5 fois son diamètre sous votre maison,
vous ne remarquerez pas le forage.
En fait, si vous arriviez à détecter le forage,
quel que soit l'instrument que vous auriez utilisé,
l'armée israélienne voudra vous le racheter très très cher
car elle essaye de détecter les tunnels du Hamas,
ou les services de douanes et de protection des frontières américaines.
Le fait est que
la terre absorbe les vibrations très efficacement,
et une fois que le tunnel est creusé sous un certain niveau,
il est indétectable.
Un sismographe très sensible
serait peut-être capable de le détecter.
CA : Vous avez donc créé une nouvelle entreprise :
The Boring Company. Excellent jeu de mots. [NdT : boring = creusant ou ennuyant]
(Rires)
EM : Qu'est-ce qui est amusant ?
CA : Combien de temps y consacrez-vous ?
EM : Environ...
2 ou 3% de mon temps.
CA : Vous vous êtes acheté un hobby.
Voici à quoi ressemblent les jouets d'Elon Musk.
(Rires)
EM : Je voulais dire que c'est en fait
un projet pour des stagiaires et des travailleurs à temps partiel.
Nous avons acheté des équipements d'occasion.
On tâtonne un peu mais on progresse bien.
CA : Donc une part grandissante de votre temps est dédiée
à créer des voitures électriques et à améliorer le transport en Tesla.
L'une des motivations à votre projet de tunnels,
est-elle la réalisation que,
dans un monde de voitures électriques et de conduite automatique,
il y aurait plus de voitures sur les routes
que jamais auparavant ?
EM : Oui, en effet.
De nombreuses personnes pensent que les voitures autonomes
pourront rouler plus vite et que cela diminuera les embouteillages.
Dans une certaine mesure, c'est vrai.
Mais dès que les véhicules autonomes partagés seront suffisamment répandus
pour rendre moins cher le trajet d'un point A à un point B,
le choix de la voiture deviendra évident, aux dépens du bus.
Cela coûtera moins cher qu'un billet de bus.
Le taux de conduite effective sera plus important avec l'autonomie partagée.
La circulation va empirer, dans les faits.
CA : Vous avez créé Tesla avec pour but de convaincre le monde
que les voitures de l'avenir seraient électriques.
Il y a quelques années, les gens se moquaient de vous.
Maintenant, plus tant que ça.
EM : C'est vrai.
(Rires)
Je ne sais pas, je ne sais pas.
CA : Mais n'est-il pas vrai que presque tous les constructeurs automobiles
ont annoncé de sérieux projets de voitures électriques
sur le plus ou moins long terme ?
EM : Oui, en effet.
Presque tous les constructeurs ont un programme d'électrification
plus ou moins sérieux.
Certains sont déterminés à faire une transition complète vers l'électrique,
d'autres n'en sont qu'à leurs balbutiements.
D'autres persévèrent dans les piles à combustible,
mais je ne pense pas que cela durera longtemps.
CA : Mais ne serait-ce pas logique, Elon,
de vous déclarer vainqueur et affirmer : « On a réussi ! »,
de laisser le monde passer à l'électrique pour vous concentrer d'autres projets ?
EM : Si.
Je compte être aux côtés de Tesla, aussi longtemps que je peux l'imaginer.
On prépare encore beaucoup de choses excitantes.
Manifestement, il y a la « Model 3 » qui arrive bientôt,
et nous allons inaugurer le semi-remorque Tesla.
CA : Oui, nous y reviendrons.
Le Model 3 est censé arriver dans le courant de juillet.
EM : Oui, la production devrait démarrer en juillet.
CA : Waouh !
L'une des caractéristiques qui enthousiasment les gens,
est sa conduite automatique.
Vous avez montré une vidéo, il y a quelque temps,
de ce à quoi ressemblerait cette technologie.
EM : En effet.
CA : La conduite automatique existe déjà dans la Model S.
Que voyons-nous sur l'écran ?
EM : Le véhicule n'utilise que des caméras et le GPS.
Il n'utilise donc pas de télédétection par laser ou de radar.
Seule de l'optique passive est utilisée, comme un être humain.
Le réseau routier est conçu pour être utilisé
grâce à l'optique passive, ou aux caméras.
Dès qu'on peut trouver une solution pour les caméras, la vision,
l'autonomie est assurée.
Sans système de vision au point, pas d'autonomie.
C'est pourquoi notre absolue priorité est de développer
un réseau de neurones convolutifs efficace en condition de conduite.
CA : De nombreux concurrents ont choisi la télédétection par laser.
Vous voulez des caméras et un radar, c'est tout.
EM : Vous pouvez tout à fait devenir superman avec des caméras uniquement.
Les caméras sont 10 fois plus efficaces que les humains.
Que des caméras.
CA : Les nouvelles voitures vendues possèdent 8 caméras.
Elles ne peuvent pas encore faire ce que la vidéo montre.
Quand en seront-elles capables ?
EM : Je pense que nous pourrons traverser le pays en complète autonomie
de Los Angeles à New York, d'ici la fin de l'année.
CA : Vous dites donc, que d'ici la fin de l'année,
quelqu'un s'assiéra dans une Tesla, ne touchera pas le volant.
Il tapera « New York », et en route !
EM : Oui.
CA : Même plus besoin de toucher le volant, d'ici la fin de 2017.
EM : Oui. En novembre ou décembre de cette année,
nous devrions pouvoir quitter notre place de parking en Californie
et rejoindre une autre place de parking à New York,
sans toucher aucun bouton durant tout le trajet.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Incroyable !
Mais c'est en partie possible
parce que vous avez déjà une flotte de Tesla qui roulent sur ces routes.
Vous accumulez une quantité importante de données sur le réseau routier national.
EM : Oui mais le plus intéressant
est que je suis assez confiant qu'on sera capable de faire ce trajet
même si on modifie activement celui-ci.
Donc c'est très simple.
C'est une chose de dire qu'il sera doué pour un trajet spécifique.
Mais le véhicule doit être capable,
une fois sur l'autoroute,
d'aller n'importe où sur ce réseau routier
dans n'importe quel pays.
Il n'est pas limité entre Los Angeles et New York.
On pourra modifier le trajet, et quitter Seattle pour la Floride,
en temps réel.
De Los Angeles, vous vous êtes rendu à New York.
Aujourd'hui, vous faites Los Angeles - Toronto.
CA : Ignorons un instant les réglementations,
en termes de technologies uniquement,
dans combien de temps quelqu'un pourra-t-il acheter une de vos voitures
et littéralement enlever les mains du volant, et s'endormir
pour se réveiller arrivé à destination,
tout ça sans danger ?
EM : Dans 2 ans, je pense.
L'astuce réside non pas dans comment garantir ça
disons, 99,9 % du temps,
car si une voiture a un accident une fois sur mille,
vous ne pourrez probablement pas dormir sur vos deux oreilles.
Vous ne devriez pas, en tout cas.
(Rires)
Ça ne sera jamais parfait.
Aucun système ne peut être parfait.
Mais si on dit, que sans doute,
la probabilité d'un accident
est de un tous les cent ans, ou tous les mille ans,
alors les gens pensent : « Bon, même si je vivais 1000 ans,
je n'aurai probablement pas d'accidents.
Ça devrait aller. »
CA : De dormir.
J'imagine que votre grande inquiétude est que les gens puissent
être tentés trop rapidement de penser être en sécurité,
qu'un horrible accident survienne et les fasse reculer.
EM : Je pense que le système autonome pourrait diminuer la quantité d'accidents
sauf dans de rares circonstances.
La chose à souligner à propos de la sécurité au volant
est qu'elle est fondée sur une approche probabiliste.
A chaque fois qu'un conducteur prend le volant, il y a une probabilité
qu'il ait un accident dont il est responsable.
Le risque zéro n'existe pas.
La question cruciale de la conduite automatique est de déterminer
à quel point la conduite autonome doit être meilleure qu'un conducteur
pour que celui-ci lui fasse confiance.
CA : Mais une fois en sécurité, sans toucher le volant,
le pouvoir de déstabilisation de l'industrie entière est énorme.
Car vous parlez de gens qui vont acheter un véhicule
qui, après les avoir déposés au travail, va s'en aller
offrir à d'autres personnes un service semblable à Uber.
C'est une source de revenus,
qui pourrait couvrir le coût d'achat de la voiture.
Bref, on a une voiture gratuite.
Est-ce vraiment possible ?
EM : Oui. Absolument. C'est ce qui va arriver.
Il y aura un parc automobile partagé
où vous achetez votre voiture,
et vous pourrez choisir de l'utiliser exclusivement,
ou que votre famille et les amis uniquement puissent l'utiliser,
ou que d'autres conducteurs notés 5 étoiles puissent l'utiliser.
Vous pourrez choisir de ne la prêter par moments.
On va y arriver.
Ce n'est qu'une question de temps.
CA : Waouh !
Vous avez évoqué le semi-remorque,
et je pense que vous prévoyez son annonce en septembre.
Mais je me demandais, pouvez-vous nous dévoiler quelque chose ?
EM : Je vais vous montrer une photo exclusive.
(Rires)
Ça vit, ce machin !
CA : OK.
EM : C'est clairement un des cas où nous voulons être prudents
au sujet des caractéristiques des voitures autonomes.
Oui.
(Rires)
CA : On ne peut pas voir grand chose,
mais cela ne ressemble pas au petit camion sympathique des voisins.
Il a l'air assez cool.
Quel genre de semi est-ce ?
EM : C'est un semi-remorque poids-lourd dédié aux longues distances.
Donc il possède la plus grosse capacité de charge
et une longue autonomie.
Il a pour but de soulager le trafic des poids lourds.
C'est quelque chose que les gens ne pensent pas encore possible.
Ils pensent que le camion n'a pas assez de puissance ou d'autonomie.
Mais avec le semi-remorque Tesla,
on veut montrer que non, un camion électrique
peut faire mieux qu'un camion à moteur diesel.
S'il y avait une compétition de tir à la corde du meilleur remorqueur,
le Tesla tirerait le diesel jusqu'en haut de la côte.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
CA : C'est cool. Pour l'instant, il n'y a pas de conduite automatique.
Mais ce sont des camions que les routiers voudront conduire.
EM : Oui. Ce qui est vraiment amusant avec un moteur électrique,
c'est que le couple n'influence pas le moment
tandis qu'avec un moteur diesel ou n'importe quel moteur à combustion,
on a une courbe en forme de colline.
Donc ce sera un camion très nerveux.
Vous pourrez le conduire comme une voiture de sport.
Il n'y a pas de vitesses, c'est une vitesse unique.
CA : Cela ferait un bon film.
Je ne sais pas quelle sera l'histoire, ou si la fin sera heureuse,
mais ce serait un bon film.
(Rires)
EM : Le test de conduite est assez étrange.
Lorsque j'ai conduit le prototype du premier camion,
c'était très bizarre quand on roule,
parce qu'on est super agile, alors qu'on est dans cet énorme camion.
CA : Vous avez déjà conduit un prototype ?
EM : Oui, je l'ai conduit sur le parking.
Je me disais : « C'est dingue. »
CA : Waouh. Ce n'est pas de la frime !
EM : On conduit ce camion géant
et on peut faire des manœuvres de fous.
CA : C'est cool. OK, on passe d'une photo « dur à cuire »
à une photo moins « dur à cuire ».
C'est une jolie maison dans « Desperate Housewives ».
Pourquoi donc ?
EM : Eh bien, cela illustre le futur,
tel qu'il va évoluer, selon moi.
Il y a une voiture électrique dans l'allée.
Si on observe l'espace entre la voiture et la maison,
on remarque trois batteries domestiques posées sur le côté de la maison.
Enfin, le toit de cette maison est un toit solaire.
C'est un vrai toit solaire vitré.
CA : Bon.
EM : C'est la photo d'une vraie, enfin, disons, une vraie fausse maison.
C'est une vraie fausse maison.
(Rires)
CA : Si je comprends bien, ces tuiles,
certaines d'entre elles, génèrent de l'énergie solaire,
EM : Ce sont des tuiles solaires en verre.
On peut en ajuster la texture et la couleur
avec une précision très fine.
Une sorte de micro-lamelle est intégrée dans le verre
de telle sorte que lorsque l'on regarde depuis la rue
ou proche du niveau du sol,
toutes les tuiles paraissent semblables,
qu'elles intègrent des cellules solaires ou pas.
On obtient ainsi un toit de couleur uniforme
depuis le niveau du sol.
Si on observe le toit depuis un hélicoptère,
on pourrait voir au travers et observer
que certaines tuiles en verre sont équipées de cellules solaires.
Du sol, c'est indiscernable.
CA : Les cellules sont placées dans les tuiles les mieux exposées
et ça rend ces toits abordables, n'est-ce pas ?
Ce n'est pas beaucoup plus cher qu'un toit de tuiles classiques.
EM : En effet.
Nous sommes persuadés que si on additionne le coût du toit
avec le coût de l'électricité,
un toit solaire en verre sera moins cher qu'un toit ordinaire
plus le coût de l'électricité.
En d'autres mots,
économiquement parlant, la solution est simple.
Nous pensons que ce sera beau,
et durable.
Nous envisagions d'offrir une garantie infinie.
Et puis on s'est aperçu
que les gens pourraient percevoir ça comme une arnaque.
Mais en fait, ce verre est renforcé.
Même si la maison s'effondre,
et qu'il n'en reste rien,
les tuiles seront encore entières.
(Applaudissements)
CA : C'est génial.
Vous allez présenter cela dans quelques semaines, je crois,
avec quatre types différents de toits.
EM : Oui, on va commencer avec deux
et les deux autres seront introduits l'année prochaine.
CA : Quelle est l'ampleur de votre ambition ?
Combien de maisons, pensez-vous, pourraient avoir ce genre de toit ?
EM : Je pense que tôt ou tard,
presque toutes les maisons auront un toit solaire.
En soulignant que l'échelle de temps ici,
est probablement de l'ordre de 40 ou 50 ans.
En moyenne un toit est remplacé tous les 20 à 25 ans.
Évidemment, on ne remplace pas tous les toits immédiatement.
Mais assez rapidement, en se projetant dans le futur,
disons dans 15 ans environ,
ne pas avoir un toit solaire sera l'exception.
CA : Y a-t-il un modèle mental que les gens ne comprennent pas
qui fait qu'avec la diminution du prix de l'énergie solaire,
la plupart des maisons ont assez de lumière sur leur toit
pour assurer tous leurs besoins ?
Si on pouvait capter cette énergie,
elle assurerait pratiquement tous leurs besoins.
On pourrait sortir du réseau.
EM : Cela dépend de la localisation,
de la taille de la maison par rapport à la surface du toit.
Mais on peut en effet affirmer
que la plupart des maisons aux États-Unis ont assez de surface de toit
pour assurer tous leurs besoins en électricité.
CA : Donc la clé pour rendre viable
les voitures, les camions et ces maisons
est le prix décroissant des batteries au lithium-ion,
sur lesquelles vous misez gros avec Tesla.
C'est en fait le cœur de vos compétences.
Et vous avez décidé
de conquérir ce savoir-faire.
Il vous suffit de construire la plus grande usine au monde
pour doubler la production mondiale de batteries lithium-ion
avec ceci. Qu'est-ce donc ?
EM : C'est la Gigafactory,
enfin son état d'avancement actuel.
On peut distinguer en regardant bien,
une forme générale en diamant.
Une fois entièrement fini, cela ressemblera à un diamant géant.
C'est l'intention en tout cas.
Il est orienté vers le nord,
mais c'est un petit détail.
CA : A terme, elle aura une capacité de production annuelle
de 100 GWh de batteries.
EM : 100 GWh. Probablement plus.
CA : On en produit déjà maintenant.
EM : La production a commencé. CA : Vous avez sorti cette vidéo.
CA : Elle tourne en accéléré ?
EM : C'est la version ralentie.
(Rires)
CA : A quelle vitesse vont-elles réellement ?
EM : A la vitesse maximum,
on ne peut pas voir les cellules sans lampe stroboscopique.
Tout est flou.
(Rires)
CA : L'une de vos idées centrales, Elon, d'un futur enthousiasmant,
est un futur dans lequel on ne sent plus coupable vis-à-vis de l'énergie.
Aidez-nous à imaginer cela.
Combien de Gigafactory nous faudrait-il pour y arriver ?
EM : Une centaine environ.
Pas 10. Ni 1000.
Environ une centaine.
CA : Je trouve cela époustouflant.
Vous pouvez imaginer ce qu'il nous faudrait
pour désintoxiquer ce monde des énergies fossiles :
vous construisez une de ces usines,
qui coûte 4,5 milliards d'euros environ,
plutôt entre 4,5 et 9 milliards d'euros.
C'est plutôt cool que vous puissiez envisager ce projet.
Et vous planifiez chez Tesla d'en annoncer deux autres cette année.
EM : Nous devrions annoncer les localisations
de deux à quatre Gigafactory cette année encore.
Oui, plutôt quatre.
CA : Waouh.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Vous n'avez pas d'autres scoops à nous offrir ?
Par exemple, où ? Sur quel continent ?
Vous pouvez dire non.
EM : On doit s'adresser au marché mondial.
CA : OK.
(Rires)
C'est super !
Je pense que nous devrions parler de...
En fait, une seconde.
Je vais vous poser une seule question politique.
La politique m'écœure, mais je tiens à vous la poser.
En ce moment, vous êtes conseiller pour un type...
EM : Qui ?
CA : qui a dit qu'il ne croyait pas au changement climatique
et beaucoup de personnes pensent que vous ne devriez pas faire cela,
elles souhaitent que vous vous en désolidarisiez.
Que leur répondez-vous ?
EM : Je pense que, premièrement,
je ne fais partie que de deux comités consultatifs
dont le format consiste en un tour de la salle
en demandant l'opinion des gens sur certains sujets.
Il y a une réunion tous les mois, tous les deux mois.
Telle est l'ampleur de ma contribution.
Mais je pense qu'il s'agit d'une salle remplie de personnes
débattant en faveur d'actions relatives au changement climatique,
ou de problèmes sociaux.
J'ai utilisé les réunions qui ont eu lieu jusqu’à présent
pour plaider en faveur de l'immigration et du changement climatique.
(Applaudissements)
Et si je n'avais pas abordé ces sujets,
personne ne les aurait mis à l'agenda.
Certes, peut-être que ça ne changera rien, mais au moins on en aura débattu.
CA : Bien.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Parlons de SpaceX et de Mars.
La dernière fois,
vous avez parlé d'un projet incroyablement ambitieux,
de développer des fusées qui seraient réutilisables.
Et c'est ce que vous avez fait.
EM : Enfin ! Cela a pris du temps.
CA : Parlez-nous-en. Que voyons-nous sur ces images ?
EM : C'est un de nos lanceurs
revenant à très grande vitesse, de très loin dans l'espace.
Il vient de larguer l'étage supérieur
à grande vitesse.
Je pense que le largage de l’étage a eu lieu à Mach 7,
ou quelque chose comme ça.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Donc cette vidéo est en accéléré ...
EM : C'était la version ralentie.
(Rires)
CA : Je pensais que c'était la version accélérée.
C'est impressionnant !
Plusieurs essais ont échoué
avant que vous ne découvriez comment y parvenir.
Maintenant, vous avez réussi environ 5 ou 6 fois ?
EM : Nous en sommes à 8 ou 9.
CA : Et pour la première fois,
vous avez re-lancé une des fusées qui avaient déjà atterri une fois.
EM : Nous avons fait atterrir un des lanceurs,
nous l'avons préparé et l'avons fait décoller à nouveau.
C'est donc la première remise en orbite d'un lanceur orbital,
la première véritable réutilisation.
Il est important de préciser que le recyclage n'est pertinent
que s'il est rapide et complet.
Comme un avion ou une voiture
où le recyclage est rapide et complet.
On ne renvoie pas son avion à Boeing entre deux vols.
CA : Je vois. Donc cela vous permet d'imaginer l'idée très ambitieuse
d'envoyer sur Mars beaucoup, vraiment beaucoup de personnes,
dans environ 10 ou 20 ans, je crois.
EM : En effet.
CA : Et vous avez créé cette fusée extravagante pour le faire.
Aidez-nous à comprendre l'ampleur de la chose.
EM : Eh bien, voici une personne.
Et voici le véhicule.
(Rires)
CA : J'ai lu que si c'était un gratte-ciel,
il aurait 40 étages.
EM : Probablement un peu plus.
Sa force de poussée est en fait...
C'est environ quatre fois la force de poussée de la fusée lunaire Saturn V.
CA : Quatre fois la force de poussée
du plus grand lanceur que l'homme ait jamais créé.
EM : Ouais. Ouais.
CA : Tout à fait normal. EM : Oui.
(Rires)
EM : Une unité de 747 est d'environ 110 tonnes de poussée.
Donc pour chaque 4500 tonnes de poussée,
on a l'équivalent de 40 Boeing 747.
C'est une poussée équivalente à 120 Boeing 747 avec tous les moteurs au max.
CA : Même avec une machine construite pour s'arracher à l'attraction terrestre,
je crois que vous avez dit
que cet engin serait capable d'emmener en orbite un 747 rempli,
des personnes, des marchandises, la totale.
EM : Exactement. Cela peut emmener un 747 chargé avec un plein de carburant,
le maximum de passagers, le maximum de marchandises.
Il peut l'emmener en tant que cargaison.
CA : Basé sur cela,
vous avez présenté récemment, un système de transport interplanétaire
qui ressemble à ceci.
Est-ce une scène que vous envisagez dans 30 ans ? 20 ans ?
Des personnes qui s'engagent vers un lanceur.
EM : J’espère le réaliser dans 8 à 10 ans.
Officiellement, c'est notre but.
En interne, nous somme plus impatients mais je pense...
(Rires)
CA : OK.
EM : Bien que le lanceur ait l'air plutôt grand,
et c'est le cas par rapport aux autres lanceurs,
je pense que les futurs vaisseaux spatiaux
le feront passer pour une simple barque.
Les futurs vaisseaux spatiaux seront énormes.
CA : Pourquoi, Elon ?
Pourquoi a-t-on besoin de construire une ville sur Mars
habitée par un million de personnes endéans votre vie ?
Je me souviens que vous avez affirmé que c'est ce que vous adoreriez faire ?
EM : Je pense qu'il est crucial d'avoir
un futur qui nous inspire et nous attire.
Je pense qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir des raisons
de se lever le matin, et de vouloir vivre.
Quelle est votre raison d'être ?
Quel est le sens ? Qu'est-ce qui vous motive ?
Qu'aimez-vous dans le futur ?
Si nous ne sortons pas de chez nous,
si le futur n'inclut pas une vie là-bas aux côtés des étoiles,
et être une espèce multiplanétaire,
je trouve ça particulièrement déprimant
de ne pas pouvoir vivre un tel avenir.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Certains relativisent ce projet.
Il y a tellement de problèmes sur Terre actuellement,
du climat à la pauvreté et bien d'autres enjeux.
Ils pensent que c'est une distraction,
que vous ne devriez pas penser à ça,
que vous devriez résoudre les problèmes existants.
Et pour être honnête, vous avez déjà bien accompli votre part
avec vos travaux sur l'énergie renouvelable,
mais pourquoi ne pas s'en tenir à cela ?
EM : Je pense qu'il y a...
Je vois le futur sous l'angle des probabilités.
C'est comme une arborescence de probabilités.
Les décisions que nous prenons affectent ces probabilités :
elles accélèrent certaines choses, en ralentissent d'autres.
Peut-être vais-je intégrer quelque chose de nouveau à cette arborescence.
Quoi qu'il arrive, l'énergie renouvelable sera.
S'il n'y avait pas Tesla, si Tesla n'avait jamais existé,
elle aurait été créée par nécessité.
C'est une tautologie.
Sans énergie renouvelable, vous avez de l'énergie non renouvelable
qui s'épuisera un jour.
Les lois de l’économie conduiront donc la civilisation
à l'énergie renouvelable.
C'est inévitable.
La valeur fondamentale d'une entreprise comme Tesla
est sa capacité à accélérer les avancées sur l'énergie renouvelable,
sa capacité à accélérer son avènement.
Lorsque je me demande
quels sont les bienfaits d'une entreprise comme Tesla,
Je dirais que si par chance,
elle accélère cette arrivée d'une décennie, peut-être un peu plus,
ce sera déjà une très bonne chose.
C'est ce que je considère être
l'aspiration fondamentale de Tesla.
En revanche, une espèce multiplanétaire qui se propage dans l'espace
n'est pas inévitable.
C'est important de souligner que ce n'est pas inévitable.
L'avenir de l'énergie renouvelable est, je pense, inévitable.
Mais que notre civilisation se dissémine dans l'espace n'est pas inévitable.
Si on regarde les avancées dans l'espace,
en 1969, on était capable d'envoyer quelqu'un sur la Lune.
En 1969.
Ensuite on a eu les navettes spatiales.
Elles pouvaient seulement atteindre les orbites terrestres basses.
Puis, les navettes ont pris leur retraite
et les États-Unis n'ont plus pu emmener quelqu'un en orbite.
C'est la tendance.
On passe de peu à rien.
Les gens se trompent en pensant
que la technologie s’améliore automatiquement.
L’amélioration n'est pas automatique.
Elle n'a lieu que si de nombreuses personnes travaillent très dur.
A l'abandon, je pense qu'au contraire, elle se dégrade organiquement.
Les grandes civilisations comme l'Égypte ancienne
furent capables de construire les pyramides.
Mais elles ont oublié comment faire.
Les Romains ont construit ces incroyables aqueducs.
Ils ont oublié comment faire.
CA : Elon, on dirait, en vous écoutant,
et au vu des choses que vous avez accomplies,
que vous avez une motivation double tout à fait unique
que je trouve si fascinante :
le désir de travailler pour l'avenir de l'humanité
et le désir de faire des choses passionnantes.
Et on dirait que l'un ne peut exister sans l'autre.
Avec Tesla, vous voulez produire de l'énergie renouvelable.
Donc vous créez ces voitures super sexy et excitantes.
Pour obtenir l'énergie solaire,
vous devez créer ces toits magnifiques.
Nous n'avons pas encore effleuré votre nouveau projet
par manque de temps,
mais vous voulez sauver l'humanité de l'IA malveillante.
Vous allez donc créer une interface cerveau-machine
qui nous donnera une mémoire infinie et la télépathie, entre autres.
Avec Mars, on a l'impression que vous nous soufflez dans l'oreille
que nous devons sauver l'humanité
et avoir un plan de secours,
mais nous devons aussi inspirer l'humanité,
et c'est un moyen d'y parvenir.
EM : Je pense que la valeur de la beauté et de l'inspiration
est très galvaudée.
Beaucoup trop.
Mais je veux être clair.
Je n'essaye pas de sauver qui que ce soit.
Ce n'est pas...
J'essaye juste d'envisager le futur
sans être triste.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Quelle merveilleuse déclaration !
Je pense que tous ceux ici présents
s'accordent sur le fait
que rien de tout cela n'est inévitable.
Le fait que votre esprit imagine
de choses dont personne n'ose rêver,
que personne ne serait capable d'imaginer
au même niveau de complexité que le vôtre.
Que vous fassiez cela, Elon Musk, est vraiment remarquable.
Merci de nous avoir permis de rêver un peu plus grand.
EM : Nous m'avertirez si je deviens réellement fou, n'est-ce pas ?
(Rires)
CA : Merci, Elon Musk. C’était vraiment vraiment fantastique.
C’était vraiment incroyable.
(Applaudissements)